foreign
to give my talk
uh the the keynote actually the
conference yep the plenary
um
the CDC went through this charade and it
was you know it was thoroughly absurd
right these did you see the video of the
votes uh no I didn't watch the these
were Zoom
Gatherings person after person masked on
their Zoom probably from their own home
right these are True Believers oh my God
who have now recommended or they just
they know it's theater
I think these were True Believers it's
worth looking at the video but I mean
true but true believers in WoW True
Believers in the cult that is now doing
so and here's the Crux of it right I
feel like this recommendation actually
crosses a boundary that for some they
will follow it across but for almost
anybody who's still got any independent
mental capacity at all the idea that
with a disease as age stratified as
covid in the hazard it poses and a
vaccine age stratified in the other
direction for its Hazard the absurdity
of recommending these vaccines for
children is
unmistakable yeah no I mean this is I
know you haven't read it yet but this is
exactly what I was writing about in
natural sections this week it is exactly
this I mean that that was this is
actually a piece that I had written
many weeks ago and I was like I'm just
looking for the right examples and we
got two of the right examples with
regard to trans and with regard to
Childhood vaccinations this week I was
like okay there it is
yeah but at some level this is now an
unmistakable atrocity yes right we are
not talking about an ambiguity we are
talking about recommending treatments
that are dangerous and in fact most
dangerous for the population in question
here we're talking about
denying people education for refusing
them for for behaving reasonably we are
going to deny people education that
isn't that is like
ghastly at an incredible level that this
would happen to children and then for
the CDC to play its game
we're not requiring these things we
don't have the authority to do or not
we're not Heavens no we're not requiring
many of you have never heard of us
before covet and now we're on everyone's
the tip of everyone's tongues but we
certainly don't have any Authority at
all how could we look at us all we did
was recommend if the states are gonna
you know children that's the state's
problem right it's just like it's
amazing and even just the mind-blowing
fact of okay
let's understand the CDC let's take it
more or less at its word
why
because it is its own reducto at
absurdum okay okay so if the idea is
well the CDC is just making a
recommendation the states of course make
their own judgments that's you know why
wouldn't the CDC under a democratic
regime be you know a championing states
rights right it's okay absurd on its
face but now let's imagine
that the states do what they are
apparently going to do you've got a
bunch of Rebel states that aren't going
to recommend these things and you've got
a bunch of states that are going to
engage in the usual slavish Devotion to
Authority and are going to require them
so now you've got a patchwork country in
which the
um
inexplicable
completely unnecessary harm to children
is going to be done on a state-by-state
basis those people who have the means to
move themselves out of states are going
to have an advantage over those who are
condemned to stay in the state that they
are in because of a job and the need for
it or who knows I mean and you know this
in sort of with the opposite political
valence uh this is true with regard to
Reproductive Rights with regard to
abortion right so you know and we've
always had the division over things like
the Second Amendment over Reproductive
Rights over death penalty but now for
you know if the election that's in a
week and a half we've got abortion and
now childhood vaccination
um against covid
on you're on on everyone's minds and
there are a lot of us who find ourselves
pulled in opposite directions by these
two things by knowing that many states
are going to go stupid on covid and
preserve uh the right to at least early
term abortion for women and that other
states are going to preserve the right
to early term uh pregnancy termination
for women and or did I say that twice
did I say the same thing twice either
way like stupid on covid and um to my
mind smart and Reproductive Rights or
the opposite like either way you've got
to take one thing that that is not is
not sane and it's not
compassion is overused and it's
weaponized but it's not compassionate
well I'm
afraid it's worse than that
um
a to the extent that what we have are
ideologies political ideologies or
political banners and that these banners
essentially have an incoherent package
of beliefs that comes with them things
that actually are not inherently related
to each other right
um but you know my team believes these
things and not those things and that
this is now going to become a geographic
phenomenon where there we are losing the
agreement that holds us together as a
nation this obviously leads in the
direction of some sort of dissolution of
that Nation
which is of course a extremely
short-sighted catastrophe and leaves
lots of us
stranded right stranded where we would
like to choose where to live as a
constitutionally protected right we
would like to choose where to live based
on things other than the ideology of the
governance structure that is the exact
opposite of living in a free country
where the the ideology of those in power
in your state is such a profound
influence in which you can and cannot do
and how you will and will not live that
it might cause you to have to move
between states that just I can't believe
we're here it's really it's really
stunning yep and both of these both of
these happened this year yeah and
um those in power in States both in red
States and in blue states are making
decisions that are causing people to
flee and uh and now it is it is quite
clear uh that we've got
um
we've got political things running in
opposite directions with regard to uh to
the Slate to the teams that have been
agreed on and this you know this is this
is in part the problem of a two-party
system there are a lot of us
who you know for us we've always voted
blue but there are a lot of people
who've always voted red who are now
going like I can't do that anymore but I
can't go blue and I was like I've always
heard of blue I can't do that anymore
but I can't go red like where where are
the options that actually represent
careful nuanced thought and care for
both individuals and recognizing that we
live in a society
and and are going to need some Society
level protections like where is that
party where are those politicians they
they exist like one person here one
person there we got Tulsi gabbard saying
I'm done with the Democrats
um but it's not as far as I know she
didn't say I'm becoming Republican
because like that's that's not an option
right like neither of these parties is
an option anymore for a very large
number of us all right so two two more
points one the division and now
increasing the geographic division right
profound enough to cause you to move
rather than just Grumble at the people
who run your state
um that thing is also causing the loss
of nuance in the positions even the
position that is closer to your own is
has lost Nuance because the point is the
people who constitute a natural break on
the perspective don't aren't in power
enough to matter right and so in other
words if it's one party rule in each
state right then what you get
is you know look I'm not
comfortable with uh the blue team's uh
complete abdication of responsibility
over Reproductive Rights as I've said
many times I I believe the right to uh
an abortion exists and that right
decreases through the you said blue team
yeah well The Blue Team seems to think
it's sophisticated to imagine that there
is nothing morally interesting that
happens at all until the moment of birth
and and the point is well I don't think
any rational rational person believes
that but if the idea is you have to
choose between you know sacred zygotes
the two the two points conception and
birth are the only moments in uh in a
human life that matter at all right in
discussing whether or not abortion
should be allowed no sorry someone else
set those as the two moments are the
ones we have to be talking about and
neither of them is the right one they're
both
intolerable and I'm not saying it you
know I actually think that the religious
perspective is tolerable at the
individual level an individual can
believe that coherently and a morally
consistent way but you can't apply it
across a population where religious
beliefs vary right that's not that's not
acceptable what's more
um you know as we talked about before
the idea that the sacredness of zygotes
is such that you have to
um you know that women have to carry the
product of rape to term right isn't is
Bonkers because the point is this
actually generates a strategy for
rapists it's not what you know it's not
what you do
um so the lack of nuance on both sides
is a disaster and the idea is that now
we're going to have to pick your poison
like which which bad philosophy do you
want to live near or live under is is
not a good thing so anyway the CDC made
its move right before I gave my talk and
I felt compelled actually
you know what kind of person would I be
if I saw a
a an atrocity a slow motion atrocity
unfolding in front of me a medical
atrocity and I didn't say so at a
medical conference so I took the risk
and I
told him exactly what I thought this
meant and exactly what it implies about
where we are in history and didn't know
how that was going to go over but it
actually I got lots and lots of positive
feedback over it I may at some point
make that uh piece I you know as you
know I don't usually I don't ever write
a talk in advance right I may have
noticed notes and know where I'm going
in this case first time in my life
I wrote it out word for word it really
needed to be precise so
um anyway that was interesting
um interesting that the conference you
know medical conference
full of people who uh I can't say that
they all shared the perspective but
enough of them did that you know the
feedback was not you're a crazy person
but it was whoa thank you for saying
that just to be clear it wasn't mostly
allopathic doctors it was mostly
naturopathic osteopaths yep yep it was a
heterodox conference for sure but you
know I I don't know what the total
number was a lot of people were uh
remote there were hundreds of people in
the room I think there was a thousand
yeah more than a thousand yeah um they
were attending some way in some way so
anyway that was that was fascinating
foreign
[Music]